>> WHAT KIND OF COFFEE DO YOU
HAVE THERE?
>> MEDIUM ROAST.
I LOVE THAT!
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T LIKE?
MISCARRIAGES.
(LAUGHTER)
♪♪
>> COFFEE, PLEASE.
YOU'RE GETTING COFFEE?
YEAH.
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT ABOUT
FREEZING YOUR EGGS?
♪♪
>> HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH BEING A
WOMAN?
♪♪
>> YOU'VE GOT A COFFEE THERE
SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THE SITUATION IN
DARFUR? DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
GO IN?
BUT YOU GOT A COFFEE. NO?
BUT YOU HAVE A COFFEE!
HOW ARE YOU DOING? YOU'RE
DRINKING COFFEE? COOL, DO YOU
DRINK ALCOHOL? I HAVE BEEN
DRINKING WAY TOO MUCH ALCOHOL.
>> SKIM LATTE? SOUNDS DELICIOUS.
WHY DO YOU THINK AMERICA HATES
BLACK PEOPLE SO MUCH.
YOU DON'T?
♪♪
>> WHAT'S THE OBSESSION WITH
WOMEN TRYING TO PUT A FINGER IN
A GUY'S BUTT.
>> IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T WANT TO
HAVE CHILDREN, IT'S JUST THAT
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE THEM
WITH HER.
>> REALLY? THAT'S (BLEEP) UP
MY BOSS PUTS SO MUCH PRESSURE
ON ME, I JUST DRINK.
I DON'T REMEMBER THE LAST TIME I
WENT TO BED SOBER
>> WOULD YOU MIND SINGING A
NEGRO SPIRITUAL WITH ME?
♪ WADE IN THE WATER ♪
♪ WADE IN THE WATER CHILDREN ♪♪
THANK YOU, MAN
>> ONE SIP.
ONE SIP
SEE, THAT'S BETTER THAN COFFEE!